[Musique]
je désire que mon mariage ne soit
l'occasion d'aucune charge nouvelle pour
le pays auquel j'appartiens désormais
est la seule chose que j'ambitionne et
de partager avec l'empereur l'amour et
l'estiment du peuple français
ainsi s'exprime le génie de mon pierrot
des comtesses espagnol est propulsé
impératrice des français en 1853 dans le
contrat de mariage il y avait aussi un
contrat de patriotisme mais il fallait
aussi qu'elles soient elles prennent à
coeur les intérêts français
ce qu'elle a fait toute sa vie au risque
de certaines erreurs politiques mais son
patriotisme français n'a jamais été
vraiment contestable placé sous les
projecteurs de l'histoire par un mariage
d'amour
présenté par napoléon iii comme une
simple affaire privée
eugénie écrit au préfet de la seine pour
l'informer de sa décision d'employer la
valeur d'une parure de diamants offerte
par la ville de paris à la construction
d'un orphelinat élevé dans le culte de
napoléon 1er
eugénie entre dans la prestigieuse
famille bonaparte en s'unissant à
napoléon iii qui premier président de la
république française
adoubé par le suffrage universel en 1848
à étouffer la république pour rétablir
lempire
dernière souveraine a régné sur la
france elle participe à cette légende
noire qui pèsent sur le second empire
les traverses près d'un siècle de
progrès et d'histoire avant de
s'éteindre à 94 ans en 1920 génie
connaît la gloire et les ors du second
empire grande ordonnatrice des
somptueuses fêtes impériale elle
converse avec stendhal et meriem et
danse en crinoline sur les airs
d'offenbach et de rossini l'impératrice
voit naître un monde nouveau
la révolution industrielle et
l'électricité
les premières automobiles et les progrès
scientifiques de louis pasteur
elle assiste à la transformation de
paris par le préfet haussmann et
l'architecte garnier inaugure le canal
de suez et arpente les expositions
universelles femmes d'affluence
elle assure la régence pendant que
napoléon iii parcours les champs de
bataille mais ses ingérences dans la vie
politique française apparaît souvent
malheureuses va être très maladroite
elle va être exigeante elle va être
cassante elle voulu elle va vouloir
assister aux réunions des ministres et
on lui devra même la guerre de 60 disent
catholiques ultramontaine elle se
prononce en faveur du pape contre
l'unification de la péninsule italienne
rêvons d'établir un vaste empire latin
catholique elle prêche une inutile
intervention militaire au mexique
désapprouvant la tournure libéral prise
par l' empire elle se montre favorable à
la guerre contre la prusse en 1870 qui
provoque l'irrémédiable chute de
napoléon iii et du second empire la
troisième république proclamée eugénie
s'exile en angleterre à charles hirst ou
l'empereur déchu l'a rejoint puis meurt
le 9 janvier 1873 celles qui voyagent
désormais sous le nom de comtesse de
pierrefonds constitue une cour discrète
dans sa villa cyrnos du cap martin et ne
sort de sa réserve qu'à l'issue de la
première guerre mondiale en communiquant
à clemenceau une précieuse lettre de
guillaume premier de prusse
ce document historique majeur daté de
1870 contribuer à la restitution de
l'alsace lorraine à la france c'est le
dernier acte politique de l'ex
impératrice
[Musique]
une
eugénie de mon tir haut né le 5 mai 1826
à grenade en espagne
elle est la fille cadette d'une
aristocrate écossaise et du compte de
thé bas soldats et homme politique
engagé au côté du premier empire et du
roi joseph bonaparte dans la guerre
d'indépendance espagnol qui enflamme la
péninsule à partir de 1800 8,7 à franz
casado fait éduquer ses enfants en
france dans le culte bonapartiste elle
est élevée comme toutes les jeunes
filles nobles de son temps elle reçoit
une éducation catholique traditionnelle
mais surtout elle a la chance d'avoir
deux professeurs de mentors auquel elle
va profondément cette tâche et et qui
vont l'accompagner toute sa vie l'un est
autre que stendhal qui lui enseigne
l'histoire essentiellement des anecdotes
glorieuse sur napoléon 1er et prosper
mérimée grand spécialiste du patrimoine
qui lui enseignera la langue française
jenny est imprégné des conquête de
napoléon 1er quand ils dominaient toutes
les nations d'europe y régnait sur près
de 40 millions de sujets son empire est
immense
à l'égal de celui de césar ou
d'alexandre le grand mais les campagnes
de russie et de france ont décimé la
grande armée et la défaite de waterloo a
conduit l'empereur faire son dernier
exil à sainte-hélène laissant la france
aux mains des bourbons louis xviii
puis charles 10 la loi du 12 janvier
1816 banny talent hors de france la
famille bonaparte en suisse au bord du
lac de constance et au château d'ars
engberg le jeune louis napoléon est lui
aussi élevé dans le culte de l'empereur
quoi de plus normal c'est un bonaparte
quand napoléon 1er son tonton était
parti pour la dernière campagne pour ce
qui serait la dernière campagne la
bataille de waterloo
il avait pris le petit louis napoléon
qu'était un tout petit bonhomme un petit
bambin sur ses genoux il avait embrassé
en lui disant toi tu seras sans doute
l'avenir de la race louis napoléon
bonaparte voit le jour rue cerruti à
paris le 20 avril 1808 accueilli par les
honneurs militaires des salves
d'artillerie qui résonne dans tout
l'empiré
il est le fils cadet d'hortense de
beauharnais fille de l'impératrice
joséphine et de louis bonaparte roi de
hollande
ce qui fait de lui le neveu de
l'empereur napoléon 1er ce dernier meurt
en captivité à sainte hélène 2 5 mai
[Musique]
le 16 septembre 1824 leroy bourbon louis
xviii c'est un son frère charles 10
monte sur le trône de france et se fait
sacrer à reims
renouant avec la tradition de l'ancien
régime les mouvements de contestation
gronde leroy tente de passer en force et
dissous la chambre des députés en
promulguant les ordonnances de saint
claud mais la surprise générale une
majorité parlementaire libéral remporte
les élections et se pose bientôt au
souverain les 27 28 et 29 janvier 1830
une nouvelle révolution éclate le peuple
parisien se soulèvent dressent des
barricades et affrontent l'armée du
maréchal mme armand ce bain de sang des
trois glorieuses renverse charles 10 la
monarchie de juillet s'installe cette
monarchie constitutionnelle arborent le
drapeau tricolore
la maison d'orléans branche cadette des
bourbons accède au pouvoir en
intronisant louis-philippe roi des
français le 9 août 1830 la monarchie de
juillet c'est la monarchie
constitutionnelle c'est même le dernier
exemple de monarchie constitutionnelle
le gouvernement de louis philippe est
apparu de plus en plus conservateur et
monarchique
sous la férule de françois guizot
le peuple a l'impression qu'on lui a
volé la révolution de 1830
ces conditions de vie se détériorent il
y à une grave crise économique qui
s'installe peu à peu dans l'esprit de
louis napoléon qui a embrassé une
carrière militaire en suisse germes
alors l'espoir d'un retour triomphal des
bonaparte mais sont toujours interdits
de séjour en france après la mort de son
frère aîné napoléon louis en 1831 et
celle du duc de reichstadt napoléon ii
en 1832 louis napoléon apparaît comme
l'héritier présomptif de la couronne
impériale
il s'emploie alors à organiser son
retour avec les chefs de file de
l'opposition en france pendant toutes
ses jeunes années
hortense va lui dire mais tu sais que tu
es le dernier espoir des bonaparte toi
seul peut faire quelque chose
alors ça va ça va les creuser des
sillons dans la tête il va d'ailleurs
partir très jeune pour faire des
tentatives de coups d'état strasbourg
qui vont échouer aussi à boulogne
également et puis il ne songeait qu'à
une chose c'était de devenir empereur le
30 octobre 1836 louis napoléon tentent
de soulever strasbourg avec une poignée
de partisans espèrent marcher sur paris
et renverser la monarchie de juillet
mais l'opération tourne vite au désastre
les comploteurs sont arrêtés et la
famille bonaparte désavoue cette
tentative de coup d'état
installé en angleterre louis napoléon
publie des idées napoléonienne affirmant
le prestige de sa filiation et
détaillant son programme politique
l'important c'est que le gouvernement
quelle que soit sa forme s'occupe du
bonheur du peuple
profitons du mouvement de ferveur
bonapartiste suscité par le rapatriement
des cendres de l'empereur en france
louis napoléon débarque avec une poignée
de fidèles dans la nuit du 5 au 6 août
1840 près de boulogne-sur-mer
cette seconde tentative de coup d'état
se soldent elle aussi par un échec
cuisant et louis napoléon est condamné à
l'emprisonnement à perpétuité à la
forteresse de agm louis-philippe le
condamne à la prison à perpétuité au
fort de ham à côté d'amiens d'ailleurs
en sortant du tribunal le futur napoléon
iii regarde le président du tribunal lui
dis est ce qu'on a déjà vu quelque chose
de perpétuels en france comme c'était un
individu turbulent qui a fréquenté la
charbonnerie qu organiser deux
tentatives de coup d'état le clan
bonaparte l'avait mis un peu à l'écart
et une réunion de famille un peu
drolatique où joseph chef de famille
peut s'écoute en parler comme d'habitude
a essayé quand même de l'écarter au
bénéfice de son cousin fils de jérôme
bonaparte
c'est assez compliqué la ligne impériale
influencé par les idées du philosophe
saint simon qui voit en ce début
d'industrialisation un moteur du progrès
social
il profite de sa captivité pour écrire
de l'extinction du paupérisme son cheval
de bataille sera dès lors la question du
mal être des ouvriers qui arrivent en
masse dans les villes pour travailler
dans les manufactures va s'évader du
fort de ham
très discrètement en prenant les habits
d'un plâtrier il se réfugie en
angleterre et en angleterre il va tomber
sous le charme dans une telle ou telle
soirée mondaine puisque il était
accueilli un peu partout le long laps
les victimes osent louis philippe et
bien été accueillies dans toutes les
soirées dans une soirée il va rencontrer
me soit radar y est howard qui est une
femme ravissante délicieuse qui est une
demi-mondaine tout de même il faut le
savoir
elle est entretenue grassement et elle
va entretenir le futur napoléon iii
le pari de 1848 est encore celui de
l'ancien régime
les épidémies la misère les conditions
d'hygiène la crise financière et
politique et toof les plus pauvres le
refus de prendre en compte les
aspirations démocratiques attise la
colère des républicains et amène le
peuple de paris à se soulever ni
philippe qui refuse de tirer sur la
foule à m'diq en faveur de son petit
fils cette révolution de 1848 renverse
la monarchie de juillet et instaure
l'éphémère deuxième république
l'espoir renaît dans l'esprit de louis
napoléon bonaparte alors comme elle est
très riche miss awards et bien
d'appartements napoléon et autorisé à
rentrer en france
il n'y a plus de loi d'exil et bien
c'est elle qui va lui financer sa
campagne électorale et l'envisagera même
de devenir impératrice évidemment le
moment venu tout le monde se gaussera en
disant que ce n'est pas une gourgandine
londonienne qui allait monter sur le
trône de france le 21 novembre 1848
l'assemblée promulgue la constitution de
la deuxième république qui instaure pour
la première fois en france une véritable
démocratie
louis napoléon se présente aux élections
présidentielles et vous savez il avait
cet avantage prodigieux de porter le nom
de napoléon et le nom de bonaparte bien
sûr parce que à ce moment là il n'y
avait pas de la campagne électorale avec
des affiches un peu partout mais il
suffisait que l'on prononce à le laisser
ces deux mots napoléon bonaparte pour
que évidemment ça rappelle des souvenirs
et des souvenirs glorieux alors que
quand on prononçait le nom de cavaignac
le nom de lamartine le nom de le de
ledru-rollin tous ceux qui qui se
présentait contre lui ça ne disait pas
grand chose dans les campagnes tandis
que napoléon
ça sonne éclair alors ya une phrase
célèbre d'adolphe thiers qui dit à
propos de nappes de louis napoléon c'est
un crétin que l'on mènera et donc
effectivement le parti de l'ordre bien
elle se sert du nom de bonaparte
c'est très important et comme le parti
de l'ordre pense que c'est quelqu'un que
l'on pourra manipuler et on ne voit que
des
avantage à soutenir la candidature de
louis napoléon à la présidence de la
république la première organisée au
suffrage universel suffrage universel un
peu restera mais quand même
et c'est à ce moment là que on découvre
que se crée ta que l'on mènera bien il a
quelques velléités à agir par lui même
d'abord il est élu avec une majorité
considérable la marque indoor récupérant
le pauvre poète que 1 ou 2% des voix je
crois lui tous les millions de voix sans
pour le napoléon bonaparte et ma foi il
peut gouverner parce que il a une
chambre qui le soutient et tout est
facile dans un premier temps pour ces
quatre années de présidence de la
république car la constitution voulais
qu'il me fut élus que pour quatre ans et
avec un mandat non renouvelable
soutenu par les conservateurs du parti
de l'ordre à 40 ans louis napoléon était
du premier président de la république
française le 10 décembre 1848
après avoir prêté serment il s'installe
au palais de l'elysée mais son amour
anglaise miss world ne peut prétendre au
titre de première dame de france
c'est la princesse mathilde la cousine
et ex fiancée du président fille de
jérôme bonaparte qui remplit les
fonctions de test de l'elysée le
président qui est un personnage original
évidemment très mystérieux qui a écrit
un livre assez obscur qui s'appelle de
l'extinction du paupérisme qui veut
supprimer la pauvreté qui a des idées
très particulières sont peut pas dire
qu'il ait vraiment l'héritier des des
lumières parce que il a des idées
qui mêle aussi le modèle britannique
l'industrialisation le saint simonisme
est alors lui prisonniers de cette
majorité conservatrice avec quand même
un piège terrible parce que on l'a fait
élire président de la république mais la
constitution qui est une constitution
très mal rédigé cette constitution de
1848 est belle ne lui reconnaît aucun
droit à re election très vite préparant
l'opinion publique
la presse bonapartiste milite pour une
prolongation du mandat présidentiel
avec l'aide son demi-frère adultérin
charles-auguste de morny louis napoléon
bonaparte fomenter un coup d'état le 2
décembre 1851 jour anniversaire du sacre
de son illustre aïeul napoléon 1er
cela permet au prince président de
conserver le pouvoir
le sénat propose alors de rétablir le
régime impérial héréditaire approuvé par
plébiscite le 2 décembre 1852 louis
napoléon devient l'empereur napoléon iii
lui le pôle et/ou à l'appart devient
empereur avec exactement comme pour cent
tentes ont dans un premier temps
c'est-à-dire charges héréditaires
lempire héréditaire s'il a un fils son
fils deviendra empereur et oui mais il
n'a pas de fils ou s'il en a ce sont des
petits bâtard qu'il a semé à droite et à
gauche car car il n'est pas marié
alors on essaye tout le monde essaye de
lui trouver une princesse de tels cours
européennes etc etc
mais il ne les trouve pas à son goût
aucune ne lui convient le génie de mon
tir haut
la petite comtesse espagnol a maintenant
22 ans elle est devenue une jeune femme
resplendissante qui fréquentent les
mondanités parisiennes et brille autant
par son élégance que par son esprit
remarquer notamment lors de réceptions
données chez la princesse mathilde
eugénie va bientôt faire partie du petit
cénacle invités dans les salons de
l'elysée
et puis un jour il préside une cérémonie
officielle le militaire dans la plaine
de satory et il y a là une femme
absolument admirable qui montre un
cheval admirable aussi et napoléon
s'approche d'elle et puis commence à lui
faire un brin de causette et ils vont se
revoir et il s'agit de dunes d'une dame
de la grande noblesse espagnol qui
s'appelle eugénie au génie de monde
d'hier ont séduit par la jeune femme
l'empereur l'invite au palais de
compiègne où l'étiquette est moins
stricte qu'à paris
lors d'une promenade génie
s'émerveillent de l'effet produit par
des gouttes de rosée sur un trèfle
lendemain son fougueux prétendant lui
offre une broche en forme de trèfle
incrusté d'émeraude et de diamants il va
lui faire une cour effrénée et eugénie
sachant bien à quel point ce napoléon
bonaparte est un coureur de jupons ne
voulait pas succomber comme ça dans un
premier temps très hâtivement
elle lui a dit mais je ne serai pas
votre votre montespan je ne serai pas
votre lavallière est en effet un soir
par exemple à compiègne ils l'abordent
la belle au génie et julie par où passe
le chemin de votre chambre par la
chapelle cire du génie est l'une des
rares dames de la cour a résisté aux
avances de l'empereur lors d'un bal
donné aux tuileries de 12 janvier 1853
la côte est s'est traité d'aventurière
par l'épousé d'un ministre
cet incident précipite la décision de
napoléon iii et il a finit par l'épouser
naturellement bien que tout le monde
contester ce mariage le vieux jérôme
disait mais bon il l'épousera beats
qu'il va épouser la première qui va se
refuser à lui le la princesse mathilde
disait mais il va l'épouser mais ça va
être un mariage
lamentable puisqu'elle n'a pas plu coeur
que de cul la cérémonie religieuse se
déroule 30 janvier 1853 dans la
cathédrale notre dame de paris
quelques jours auparavant napoléon iii
déclarait devant les institutions
impérial celle qui est devenue l'objet
de ma préférence et d'une naissance
élevé française par le choeur par
l'éducation par le souvenir du sang que
verse à son père pour la cause d'un
empire tous et de toutes les qualités de
l'âme elle sera l'ornement du trône
comme au jour du danger elle deviendrait
un de ces courageuses appui catholique
et pieuse
elle adressera au ciel les mêmes prières
que moi pour le bonheur de la france je
viens donc messieurs dire à la france
j'ai préféré une femme que j'aime et que
je respecte a une femme inconnue dont
l'alliance hutues des avantages mais les
deux sacrifices sans témoigner de dédain
pour personne je cède à mon penchant
mais après avoir consulté ma raison et
mes convictions
enfin en plaçant l'indépendance les
qualités de coeur le bonheur de famille
au dessus des préjugés dynastique
je ne serai pas moins fort puisque je
serai plus libre mais la lune de miel
est de courte durée
devenue impératrice des français jenny
est bien vite délaissée par son époux le
16 mars 1856 elle donne naissance au
prince impérial eugène louis napoléon
eugénie a réussi avec beaucoup de
beaucoup de mal parce qu'elle a fait
beaucoup de fausses couches à avoir un
enfant
le prince impérial et puis elle elle
s'ennuie elle s'ennuie pourquoi parce
que son mari l'a complètement délaissé
napoléon iii il avouera d'ailleurs eu
lieu j'ai été fidèle six mois tout de
même à mon épouse la pérennité du trône
est assurée par la naissance du prince
impérial
il s'agit à présent de forger le
prestige du second empire d'éblouir et à
ce jeu jenny tient le premier rôle
c'est elle qui va orchestrer les
fameuses séries de compiègne où se
retrouvent des invités de marque qu'à
cotonou grosso modo entre octobre et
décembre et bien napoléon iii et eugénie
vont prendre l'habitude de lancer des
invitations à des séries d'invités dont
le nombre varié oscillé entre 60 et une
centaine d'invités rassemblés en même
temps pour une durée de sept à huit
jours consécutifs
ici à compiègne et on organise les
grandes soirées on appelle ça les
compiègne on ferait un train qui mène
tous ses admirateurs et ses amis jusqu à
compiègne les écrivains mairie mais
certaines de ses maîtresses et offenbach
également qui va jouer ces opérettes à
compiègne et c'est vraiment le centre de
joie et de d'amusement du second empire
compiègne trice accueil à compiègne
l'architecte garnier les peintres de la
croix dorée
les écrivains flaubert dumas ou encore
des savants comme louis pasteur
on va inviter des hommes de lettres on
va inviter des savants va inviter des
artistes mais principalement une fois
quand même pas se cacher que c'est
presque majoritairement la cour
l'entourage des souverains les membres
de la maison de l'empereur et de
l'impératrice qui sont les plus nombreux
autour d'eux la seule obligation qui est
faite aux invités des séries c'est de
dîner le soir en habit à la table de
l'empereur sans quoi dans la journée
tout le monde est libre de faire ce
qu'il lui plaît
l'hospitalité et de rigueur et l'éthique
est réduite à sa plus simple expression
ou pratiquer la chasse et des promenades
en forêt l'architecte eugène viollet le
duc dirige la visite des travaux du
château de pierrefonds commandité par le
couple impérial
les tableaux vivants charades et
parodies constituent les divertissements
à la mode
particulièrement appréciée par
l'impératrice
donc elle a évidemment quitter compiègne
à la fin du second empire on est à la
fin des années 1860 lorsqu'elle vient
pour la dernière fois et elle reviendra
en 1910 dans une visite incognito
et effectivement on a la relation d'un
tout petit groupe de personnages dont
une dame vêtue de noir âgé et voilée qui
visitent les appartements et qui
arrivait dans le salon des fleurs qui a
été la chambre du jeune prince impérial
et bien se trouvent mal et demande à sa
soirée c'est là qu'on révèle au
personnel que c'est l'impératrice
eugénie qui demandent à se recueillir un
petit moment tout seul dans cet espace
qui a été la chambre de son fils les
souverains les cours plus anciennes
regardez un peu avec hauteur ce qui se
passait à paris et bien napoléon iii et
eugénie au ébloui l'europe par
luxe et la beauté des fêtes et des
réceptions qui se déroulait à paris
pour toutes ces grandes occasions
napoléon iii pilleurs après son mariage
avec jenny était très soucieux de donner
un lustre est apparent il est très
soucieux de développer aussi le les
industries du luxe de développer des des
stations thermales c'est notamment l'âge
d'or de biarritz biarritz où l'on
construit une immense villa pour la
princesse eugénie qui deviendra plus
tard l'hôtel du palais qui deviendra une
grande station de villégiature pour non
seulement les français riches mais aussi
pour les personnes aisées du monde
entier pour la gentry tout ça donne au
second empire
une ambiance à peu près extrêmement
luxueuse et en même temps sulfureuse
parce qu'évidemment tout le monde n'en
profite pas
[Musique]
en 1854 à la suite de la déclaration de
guerre entre la russie et l'empiré
ottoman la france s'engage aux côtés de
l'angleterre et s'allie aux turcs dans
la guerre de crimée qui va durer
jusqu'en 1856 cet engagement permet à
napoléon iii de rétablir le prestige de
la france sur la scène européenne
en obtenant la capitulation de la russie
après la destruction de sa flotte à
sébastopol et la fameuse bataille de
malakoff
mais derrière l'image prestigieuse de
lempire génie à napoléon iii demeurent
les souverains de régimes répressifs et
autoritaires les libertés de réunion et
d'association sont suspendus et la
presse et censurer toute opposition au
second empire et étouffé la vie
politique semble figée rythmée par les
fêtes impériale qui gomme les débats
parlementaires le 14 janvier 1858
napoléon iii et son épouse se rendent à
l'opéra de la rue le peletier quand une
énorme détonation souffre les vitrines
des magasins et projettent leur carrosse
à plusieurs mètres
le couple impérial est sain et sauf mais
cet attentat perpétré par orsini sera
près de 150 blessés à la suite de cet
attentat d'orcines et le régime se
durcit
sous l'autorité du général espinasse et
une loi de sûreté générale est votée
cette loi permet d'arrêter d'exil et
tous les opposants soupçonnés de menacer
le régime
pourtant napoléon iii estime qu un
pouvoir fort ne peut se bâtir que sur la
démocratie et il estime que ce pouvoir
doit se fonder sur le consentement du
peuple
il va donc le rétablir le suffrage
universel
mais il ne faut pas se leurrer si les
présenter comme démocratique par le
pouvoir
ce régime n'est en aucun cas libéral
l'administration impériale et toute
puissante l'arsenal répressif est bien
rodé la police traque les opposants la
presse approuve ou se tait et le pouvoir
gouverne sans partage
napoléon iii est bien conscient que l'
empire autoritaire n'est pas viable à
long terme
il cherche donc de nouveaux appuis
auprès des forces sociales qui le
combattent
il mise sur la politique extérieure et
promet à victor emmanuel ii roi de
piémont-sardaigne d'intervenir en faveur
de l'unité de la péninsule voulue par
les patriotes italiens en échange de la
savoie et de nice
eugène est une catholique ultramontaine
c'est à dire qu'elle est favorable à la
primauté spirituel et juridictionnelles
du pape sur le pouvoir politique et elle
va soutenir le pape pin
qui est contre cette unification de la
péninsule italienne amorcé par victor
emmanuel 2 parce que qui dit unification
dit fin des privilèges de rome bien en
1859 la france entre en guerre contre
l'autriche et l'impératrice va devoir se
ranger du côté de napoléon iii très
naturellement
l'empereur napoléon iii a une totale
confiance en son épouse et il va le lui
témoignèrent de reprise puisque
lorsqu'il est amené à prendre la tête de
l'armée eh bien il va devoir quitter
paris la capitale les tuileries et donc
en deux occasions il va confier la
régence à l'impératrice eugénie
donc c'est une preuve évidemment de
grande confiance et c'est c'est là on
peut dire que l'impératrice aura pu
avoir une influence sur des décisions à
prendre lorsque l'empereur est absent et
il est ton loin le conflit éclate entre
l' empire austro-hongrois de françois
joseph et la coalition franco sarde
précipitant les deux camps dans la
campagne d'italie 2008 159 l'impératrice
expérimental or l'exercice du pouvoir en
assurant la régence pendant que napoléon
iii arpente les champs de bataille de
magenta et de solférino
après son succès en italie l'empereur
hésitent encore face à une
libéralisation du régime qu'il sait
pourtant indispensable
pouvoir opte donc pour une sorte d'
empire social en donnant davantage de
liberté au parlement aux hommes
d'affaires aux collectivités locales et
aux ouvriers en leur accordant le droit
de grève et la liberté syndicale
il réforme le système bancaire pour
favoriser l'essor industriel
c'est l'âge d'or des élites
administratives des hommes d'affaires et
des banquiers
il crée des banques de dépôt et favorise
le crédit foncier
c'est la naissance du crédit foncier de
france pour le monde agricole du crédit
immobilier pour financer les sociétés
industrielles ou encore du crédit
lyonnais dans cette période absolument
clé du 19e siècle et bien quand arrive
le second empire
malgré tout les côtés autoritaire le
côté répressif pendant longtemps
au début tout au moins du jus du second
empire qui doit s'affirmer avec quand
même une apparence de dictature et bien
les décisions sont prises qui ont très
heureux effet sur le plan économique
l'empereur met fin au protectionnisme
économique en négociant secrètement un
traité commercial avec l'angleterre
abolissons notamment les droits de
douane sur les matières premières et
produits alimentaires textile et
métallurgique cette mesure d'abord
impopulaire auprès des industriels
français permet la modernisation des
modes de production dans les années 1860
lempire prend une tournure de plus en
plus libérale c'est une période
extraordinaire développement économique
industriel
alors évidemment c'est ça à son mauvais
côté l'affairisme la spéculation mais en
fait les rênes de l'état et très
solidement tenue la période est quand
même celle de l'explosion
des découvertes des inventions de
l'industrie napoléon iii mis sur la
révolution industrielle les avancées
scientifiques et techniques en soutenant
les travaux de louis pasteur et en
appuyant le projet de ferdinand de
lesseps de percer le canal de suez
inauguré par l'impératrice eugénie de 17
novembre 1869
[Musique]
l'empereur entreprend la construction du
réseau ferroviaire français
l'état s'engage à leur financièrement
contribuant au développement
d'entreprises sidérurgiques de travaux
publics afin de réaliser des milliers de
kilomètres de voies ferrées qui
desserviront en 1866 toutes les moyennes
et grandes villes du pays
[Musique]
il lance un gigantesque chantier de
construction du réseau routier puis de
développement des voies navigables avec
la création de canaux et de grandes
compagnies maritimes messageries
maritimes compagnie générale
transatlantique
et
sur le modèle de londres napoléon iii
veut faire de paris une capitale moderne
débarrassé de son visage moyen-âgeux de
sa réputation d'insalubrité et de
surpopulation
il a fait appel 1 un monsieur prodigieux
qui est le préfet haussmann pour
transformer véritablement paris c'est à
dire que toutes les petites ruelles
obscures sombre etc vont être détruites
et on va tracer les grandes artères que
l'on connaît toujours aujourd'hui les
grands boulevards sont les boulevards
créée à l'instigation de napoléon iii
georges eugène haussmann nommé préfet de
la seine en 1853 reçoit donc la mission
d'aérer d'unifier et d'embellir paris
c'est un chantier perpétuel c'est à dire
les parisiens deux époques et bars on
leur dit qu'ils vont avoir de très beau
boulevard qui valeur des ronds points
comme la place de l'étoile une ville
absolument moderne et et aérée avec des
jardins publics le parc montsouris le
parc monceau tout ça tout ça est en
gestation et pendant la période même du
renne tout ça est lancé un rythme fou et
a énormément d'expropriation et cetera
paris est donc un chantier bosman
imagine une ville nouvelle percée de
grands boulevards dax de communication
reliant les grandes gares un modèle
d'architecturé découpé en vingt
arrondissements où tous les citoyens
trouveront leur place
évidemment il y avait dans son intention
certainement le fait d'embellir la
capitale mais aussi il se disait que en
cas d'émeutes comme il y en avait eu à
la révolution de 48 sous louis philippe
est bien dans les grandes artères
on pouvait quand même maîtrisé la foule
beaucoup plus facilement que dans toutes
les petites ruelles
il va faire ouvrir et crée l'opéra
l'opéra garnier compte génie pose la
question d'ailleurs à garnier 10 mai 7
quel style c'est du style napoléon iii
majesté répond dernier c'est à ce moment
là dans les années 1880 puis après et a
fortiori 1900 que les parisiens
toucheront quelque sorte les dividendes
du second empire avec leurs très belles
avenues très dégagée c'est aussi
l'émergence des grands magasins le tout
paris se pressent au bon marché au
printemps à la samaritaine et de
nouveaux édifices publics sortent de
terre comme l'hôtel dieu où le théâtre
du châtelet mais la transformation de
paris coûte cher les détracteurs
d'haussmann qui le surnomme l'attila de
l'expropriation vont bientôt l'accusé
d'avoir mal géré et chasser les pauvres
de la capitale
dans son sillage la révolution
industrielle entraîne un culte du
progrès qui s'expose à paris entre 1855
et 1937 lors de grandes expositions
universelles
véritable vitrine technique et
artistique
elle témoigne de la puissance de la
vitalité économique et de la maîtrise
technologique des nations elles ont
aussi pour mission de permettre les
échanges du savoir entre les ingénieurs
et créateur des différents pays qui
possèdent leur pavillon dans la rue des
nations
éphémères ou durables l'architecturé est
à l'honneur l'histoire retient la
construction des palais de l'industrie
et des beaux-arts pour l'édition 2008
155 celle de la tour eiffel et du métro
parisien en 1889
[Musique]
pendant le second empire c'est
l'expansion considérable de la france
c'est à dire que napoléon 1er lui avait
un petit empire colonial de 70 mille
kilomètres carrés je crois eh bien ça va
être multiplié par dix voire parfum
parce que c'est en effet à cette époque
là que l'on commence vraiment à
s'installer en algérie que l'on fait du
maroc un protectorat qu'on a le sénégal
qu'on a la guinée quant à la cochinchine
le cambodge la polynésie en feu se
développe un peu partout on devient
lempire français devient quasiment aussi
important que l' empire de la reine
victoria
eugénie a une haute idée de lempire de
la fonction qui lui échoit
elle entend donc jouer un rôle politique
au sommet de l'état en conseillant et en
2d dans napoléon iii gênés pour se
distraire a voulu se lancer dans la
politique
il a laissé faire parce que ils
voulaient surtout qu'on le laisse
tranquille
l'une ne te pas quelqu'un de qui accable
et son entourage
l'impératrice profite de cette marche de
manoeuvre et dès 1862 elle tente
d'influencer son époux en faveur d'une
expédition au mexique afin de créer un
empire latin catholique et d'explorer de
nouveaux débouchés économiques rompu
lors de la guerre en italie eugénie
convainc napoléon iii de proposer la
couronne du mexique au frère de françois
joseph maximilien de habsbourg
mais en 1865 la guerre de sécession
s'achève et le gouvernement américain
soutient les troupes rebelles obligeant
napoléon iii a abandonné le mexique
maximilien qui refusent d'abdiquer et
fusillé 19 juin 1867 anéantissant les
efforts de rapprochement franco
autrichien en 1867 1868 la vie politique
française semble renaître l'empereur
annonce une série de réformes libérales
en fait il s'agit de demi-mesure
tempérée par un veto du sénat il y à une
libéralisation de la presse une plus
grande liberté de réunion un droit
d'interpellation pour les députés et les
sénateurs
napoléon forme un nouveau gouvernement
avec à sa tête le république à emile
ollivier eugénie tisse alors son
influence politique
en s'alliant à eugène drouaire qui était
l'un des piliers de lempire autoritaire
qui considérait que l'expédition
mexicaine était une grande idée et qui
évidemment désapprouve ce virage libéral
pris par l' empire
dans ce contexte le gouvernement olivier
apparaît extrêmement fragile et en 1870
il va se révéler incapables d'éviter la
guerre à cette époque là c'est à dire en
70 la prusse est en train de réunifier
autour d'elle toute l'allemagne avec un
chancelier qui a les dents longues qui
s'appelle otto von bismarck et bismarck
pour véritablement scellé son son empire
allemand celui qu' il n'y a qu'une seule
chose à faire c'est une bonne guerre
contre la france le 21 juin 1870 le
prince franco-allemand léopold ii ol zoo
l'herne singh beringen se voit proposer
le trône d'espagne vacant depuis deux
ans mais la france y opposent
farouchement
et demande au roi de prusse par
l'intermédiaire de son ambassadeur
benedetti la confirmation écrite du
retrait de léopold
lise parc le chancelier de prusse rédige
la fameuse dépêche james qui suggère que
l'ambassadeur français a été congédié de
manière humiliante
aussitôt la presse parisienne crient au
scandale excitant les velléités
guerrières du peuple et des
parlementaires
les français se sentent mise au défi et
de façon un peu absurde
il ya un parti belliciste qui se crée
autour de l'impératrice eugénie
notamment pas tellement près de napoléon
iii qui était pas très favorable à la
guerre napoléon iii ne voulait pas cette
guerre de 70 et 7 e génie qui s'est
cabré en lui disant si on ne la fait pas
à cause de toi
l'empiré déshonorait on se lance dans la
guerre on déclare la guerre alors que
rien n'est prêt que
il n'ya pas stratégies militaires
arrêtés il demande à son ministre de la
guerre qui s'appelle maréchal leboeuf
est ce que nous sommes prêts leboeuf qui
n'a jamais mis le pied dans une caserne
multi mais enfin majesté nous avons des
boutons de guêtre en réserve pour dix
générations
le 19 juillet 1870 la france déclare la
guerre à la prusse
quand la guerre est déclarée à la
demande de génie et bien napoléon monte
au front et s'aperçoit que les soldats
cherchent leurs officiers que les
officiers chercheurs soldats que l'armée
dans une débandade totale
l'empereur lui même est très malade mais
il veut prendre le commandement des
troupes et surtout sa femme veut qu'il
donne l'exemple du réarmement moral
tout ça pourquoi ben parce que l' empire
c'est est libéralisée on était en train
de faire quelques concessions
ce que l'on appelait les rouges et il y
avait tout un party belliciste qui
voulait que en faisant la guerre est
bien imposer des sacrifices aux français
leur redonnait le sens des valeurs de
l'identité à paris eugénie assure la
régence
elle remplace le ministère olivier par
un cabinet sous la houlette du très
conservateur compte de palikao pendant
ce temps l'empereur déambulent malades
sur le champ de bataille il a été
pathétique on a souvent dit d'ailleurs
qu'il était plutôt suicidaire il essaie
de se faire tuer pendant cette guerre
ça a été affreux debout temps beau les
soldats de l'armée prussienne sont plus
nombreux et mieux préparés très vite
pour les français la guerre tourner au
cauchemar et les défaites s'accumulent
le 2 septembre 1870 les troupes de
napoléon iii sont encerclés à sedan et
au terme de la bataille
l'empereur lui même est fait prisonnier
[Musique]
à paris les républicains demandent la
déchéance de l'empiré la foule prend
d'assaut le palais bourbon
jenny se réfugie chez le docteur evans
en américain qui organise sa fuite vers
l'angleterre le 4 septembre 1870 léon
gambetta jules favre et jules-ferry
proclame la république et constituent un
gouvernement provisoire de défense
nationale celui ci ordonne au peuple
français de résister face à l'armée
prussienne qui encercle la capitale et
on ne peut pas être très indulgent pour
la paix a très seul génie parce que elle
a toujours voulu que l'empereur reste au
front elle n'a pas voulu qu'ils
redescendent à paris alors que lui
voulait protéger paris il voulait
surtout être à paris pour prendre des
décisions
il n'a pas pu alors après évidemment
génisses rachètera ça deviendra une
épouse exemplaire pendant la période de
l'exil en angleterre ce couple
pour l'histoire apparaîtra complètement
unis avec une impératrice dévouée à son
mari au moment de la guerre de 1870
on peut se poser la question de savoir
si elle n'a pas eu un rôle beaucoup plus
pernicieux
[Musique]
et
le 23 octobre 1870 réfugiés a child arst
en angleterre eugénie écrite au roi de
prusse guillaume premier pour l'implorer
de renoncer aux territoires occupés en
alsace le souverain explique son refus
dans une lettre datée du 26 octobre
dernier acte politique de génie sera de
remettre en 1918 à georges clemenceau
cette pièce historique majeur qui va
largement contribuer au retour de
l'alsace lorraine dans le giron de la
france à l'issue de la première guerre
mondiale
les termes de cette lettre prouve qu'en
1870 le roi de prusse victorieux ne
réclame pas l'alsace en tant que
territoire allemand mais seulement comme
un glacis de protection face à
d'éventuelles invasions française c'est
à partir de ces considérations que le
retour de l'alsace lorraine à la france
est alors inscrit parmi les buts de
guerre
l'empereur déchu rejoint son épouse en
angleterre où il meurt le 9 janvier 1873
l'impératrice eugénie donc varl
poursuivre l'éducation de son fils qui
va vouloir entrer dans une école
militaire anglaise chose à laquelle
finira par se ranger l'impératrice qui
ne voyait pas ça d'un très bon oeil au
départ j'ai n'y perdra aussi son fils le
prince impérial
engagé volontaire dans l'armée
britannique en afrique du sud et tué à
23 ans par lise houle pour les anglais
c'est vraiment l'incarnation du jeune
héros qui meurt en brave et alors que
les français au presque totalement
oublié ce jeune prince dont on ne
connaît guère que sa mort c'est
évidemment quelque chose d'assez
tragique pour l'impératrice qui perd
d'abord l'empereur napoléon iii puis
ensuite son fils unique
seul enfant qu'elle ait eu alors
qu'elle-même va vivre très âgées puisque
elle a traversé toute la fin du 19e
siècle et le début du xxème du génie
qui voyagent désormais sous le nom de
comtesse de pierrefonds constitue une
course discrète dans sa vie l'un cyrnos
du cap martin où elle reçoit notamment
son ami l'impératrice sissi
alors elle était très active on peut la
rapprocher faire un petit parallèle avec
elisabeth d'autriche la fameuse si si
comme elle c'est une femme dynamique une
femme d'action
l'impératrice eugénie aimait beaucoup
marcher et même crapahuter on peut dire
et donc elle partir du moment où elle
s'est retrouvée seule et bien elle va
entraîner avec elle dame de compagnie
etc dans des marches qui vont durer des
heures
elle va se faire construire une villa
sur la côte d'azur au cap martin elle va
s'offrir un yacht
elle va voyager donc elle sera
extrêmement active jusqu'à la fin de son
existence
à luton 1870 le gouvernement provisoire
doit asseoir sa légitimité et en même
temps organiser la lutte contre l'armée
prussienne qui approchent dangereusement
de paris les prussiens vont venir vers
paris parce que bismarck à tintin dans
l'intention de faire proclamer la
création de l' empire allemand à
versailles dans la galerie des glaces
n'est plus ni moins et on va se defendre
naturellement paris va résister mais on
ne va pas les potions ne vont pas
chercher à envahir paris ils vont
l'encercler ceinture et paris et laissés
paris agen comme ça pendant plusieurs
mois on va connaître un siège absolument
abominable on sera obligé de manger tous
les rats tous les chiens tous les
oiseaux tous les animaux du jardin
d'acclimatation on mourait de faim à
paris le 18 janvier 1871
guillaume premier est proclamé empereur
allemand dans la galerie des glaces du
château de versailles le traité de
francfort signé le 10 mai 1871 met
officiellement fin à la guerre
il oblige la france a cédé l'alsace
lorraine et à payer une indemnité de
guerre s'élevant à 5 milliards de francs
or le peuple français se sentent
humiliés
alors quand hier ben désarmé paris après
avoir signé l'armistice avec bismarck un
nouveau soulèvement gronde la commune de
paris le pouvoir réfugiés à versailles
abandonne la capitale aux
révolutionnaires sur le modèle de la
révolution française
cette commune entame un bras de fer
contre les versaillais et met en place
des réformes sociales le 21 mai 1871
l'armée versaillaise forcer les portes
de la capitale
marquant le début de ce que l'histoire
retiendra comme la semaine sanglante
la violence des incendies et des
exécutions sommaires
l'acharnement des combats et
l'impitoyable répression demeure sans
équivalent au 19e siècle la commune et
écraser le mouvement socialiste décapité
mais l'idée républicaine survie et va
s'enraciner dans les années 1880
malgré les crises profondes qu'elle va
traverser la sphère dreyfus et la
première guerre mondiale la troisième
république qui va durer 70 ans est en
régime solide fondé sur une nouvelle
trinité liberté laïcité souveraineté de
la nation
l'école devient un facteur de la
construction nationale l'enseignement
primaire y est gratuit et obligatoire
la loi du 6 décembre 1905 entérine la
séparation de l'église et de l'état
le débat politique évolue pour faire
valoir les droits de chaque catégorie
sociale et la société d'ordres laisse
place à une société de classe
il ya toute une école aujourd'hui de
réhabilitation napoléon iii il a été
longtemps détesté parce qu'il a eu un
adversaire redoutable sur le plan
littéraire qui était victor hugo et ça a
été la condamnation pendant très
longtemps puis la troisième république
s'est bâti un peu sur la critique du
second empire et toute la troisième
république ça une importance énorme pour
la transmission des connaissances aux
français l'école communale l'école
primaire on a appris le second empire
par les adversaires du second empire
sont eux qui nous ont enseigné le second
empire d'eau qu'il faut aujourd'hui un
petit peu navigué à contre courant mais
pas trop loin parce qu'il faut essayer
de de cerner
la vérité à peu près objectivement si
c'est possible et on sait que on a un
peu trop critiquer on est allé trop loin
dans la critique du second empire
eugénie a traversé un siècle d'histoire
de progrès et de bouleversements
politiques et sociaux
elle a aimé la france mais souvent pris
de malheureuse décision elle a vu son
monde s'écrouler et un nouvel ordre
naître ce n'est qu'en 1920 au terme
d'une très longue fille que
l'impératrice eugénie dernière
souveraine de france rejoint son époux
et son fils dans le mausolée qu'elle a
fait construire au sud de l'angleterre à
farnborough où la famille impériale
repose aujourd'hui encore